[Music]
Chipley it's howl answer the phone
Colonel Taylor where's Shipley I'm with
him right now he's in pretty bad shape
all right listen to me did you locate
the weapon yeah
I'm with it describe it it's a kid it's
a kid that make it into some kind of kid
that's the weapon what I can't reach you
you have to bring it to me do you
understand no Shipley can't move I'm
easy he's not looking good at all
we're getting out right
now then you know what you have to do
kill it what look
[Applause]
how
When The War started
they protected me
took better care of me than humans sort
of
they're not people Maya
it's just programming
ten years ago today the artificial
intelligence created to protect us
[Music]
very existence
Sergeant Taylor we are this close to
winning the war
but the AI are developing a super weapon
retrieve it
they went
[Music]
did you locate the weapon yeah it's just
a kid
no
you gotta be a good person to go to
heaven so we're just saying we can't go
to heaven because you're not good
and I'm not a person
you're gonna do other things
she looks like a little girl now but
she's growing
Whoever has that kid wins the war
[Applause]
foreign
wants to be free
we don't have that in the fridge how
about ice cream
[Music]